i've seen your requests i've read your
comments so here we go intermittent
fasting i'm dying to talk to you about
this i eat for eight hours and i fast
for 16. i can feel the difference before
we get into the pros and cons and if you
should do it let's talk about what
intermittent fasting actually is human
fasting is not a new concept by any
means humans have been doing it for a
millennia intermittent fasting is just a
rebranding of something that we have
already been doing our bodies enter a
fasting state every time we're asleep
some people do intermittent fasting and
not even know it i mean there's plenty
of times where i had a stressful
rotation in medical school or difficult
job in the hospital where i didn't have
time to eat breakfast that's a form of
intermittent fasting and our bodies are
totally capable of handling this i know
what you're thinking i don't want to
starve myself for health benefits
intermittent fasting is not starving
when you're fasting your body is using
stored nutrients and stored energy forms
in order to make your body continue to
function when you're starving you've run
out of those energy sources and are
breaking down vital tissues like organs
to get that same energy there are many
different ways to go about going on one
of these diets and that not only makes
it confusing for you but that also makes
it very difficult to do research on it
to find out how effective it truly is
because if there are multiple ways to do
it we have to be able to test each one
of those ways the 16-8 diet which is uh
not eating during 16 hours of the day
alternate day fasting where you eat one
day fast the other day five and two were
two days of the week that you're fasting
there's no hard and fast rule saying
that this is the correct way of doing it
you may be wondering how is iaf
beneficial to me there's been a lot of
proposed health benefits many of them
have been proven within animal studies
or lab models which is not the same
thing as being proven in a human model
but they are very promising now those
benefits include increased mental
sharpness a favorable hormonal profile
weight loss decreases of inflammation
within the body decreases of certain
diseases within the body how can iaf
help you lose weight you have an
increase in growth hormone a decrease in
insulin and that alone will help you
lose weight next because you're skipping
meals or even going days without eating
meals it's very likely that when you
look throughout the week you'll be
eating fewer calories our thinking is
that during eight hours you'll eat less
than you would if you were eating during
16 hours let's talk about these other
health benefits we know that chronic
stress is not good for the body the body
is just not meant to be chronically
stressed out it's not meant to have a
high heart rate high blood pressure
intermittent fasting is really a form of
acute short-term mild stress this type
of acute short-term stress is really
good for the body what can we use as a
metaphor here let's take exercise
exercise is a form of acute mild stress
what happens after exercise we have
benefits for the brain we have benefits
for weight loss we have benefits for
disease prevention now similarly when
you stress your body through
intermittent fasting there are some
benefits
more autophagy which is the removal of
cellular waste
more production of neurotrophic factors
which protect your brain and a favorable
hormonal profile with increases in human
growth hormone and norepinephrine let's
talk about some of the shortcomings of
if primarily there's not enough guidance
of what you should eat we don't know how
many calories we don't know what foods
to eat on the days or times that you
actually are eating second we don't know
which form of if is best
third there are some side effects when
you are fasting that people do
experience headaches mental fog
heartburn these things do exist it's not
totally benign four we don't know the
consequences of following an
intermittent fasting diet long term most
if not all of these studies are done on
the short term if you are eating a very
unhealthy diet and then make a change
you're definitely going to see a benefit
but now does this benefit still hold up
one two three ten years down the line we
don't know that yet when it comes to iaf
and five it's not easy for everybody to
fight off those cravings on fasting days
all right my final take on if i think
it's a great concept with some really
promising medical research behind it i
think that if you can skip a meal you
can skip a breakfast here and there
you're gonna see some benefits does that
mean you should go on this very rigid
diet where you're doing the five and two
or sixteen and eight i don't think we
should quite make this a religious
rigorous part of our everyday life
because we don't know the long-term
consequences of it but in a society
that's prone to overeating a fasting day
won't hurt and will probably help as
always stay happy and healthy so here we
go intermittent fasting kind of a
intermittent yeah it was like borderline
our bodies have adapted to this sort of
fasting period because of
throughout the millennium
many people are doing this already and
not not
our bodies are totally capable and have
adapted to not being filled with food 24
hours a day why are you laughing
creating more mitochondria which is the
energy making machinery of the cell
energy making which is the energy center
of the cell
so
[Music]